if people focused on what they dominated  at and not tried to be something else  they would win it is just so obvious to  me who's winning and who's losing a lot  of people look at finished products they  look at LeBron today they look at  Beyonce today trying to win and not  being scared and not fearing that loss  because of others not yourself I want to  be where you are  go what la can do something I don't know  other people's POV everybody here  doesn't like losing cuz they're worried  what other people think about their loss  that's the number one thing that holds  people back to me self-awareness is what  are you good at what do you like what  puts you in a position to be successful  if I didn't have the passion for the  game I wouldn't do it too many people  want to be something versus recognizing  what they are and it's the people that  understand themselves first that are  winning